This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Around the corner from our office in beautiful downtown Oakland, California is DeLauer's new stand. It has been there since 1907. For the people who live in work downtown, it is central to our existence. Everyone goes there to buy drinks, lottery tickets, little packs of fruit flavored sigareloves, and occasionally, even a newspaper. 163. But about eight months ago, it became clear that even though Delaur's wants a bunch of people inside the store buying things, they don't want a bunch of people outside their store hanging out on
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心，离我们办公室不远的地方，有一家DeLauer报刊亭。它自1907年起就一直存在。对于在市中心工作和生活的人来说，它是我们生活中的核心。每个人都会去那里买饮料、彩票、小包水果味香烟，偶尔还会买份报纸。但大约八个月前，情况变得很明显，尽管DeLauer希望店里有很多人买东西，但他们并不希望店外有很多人在人行道上闲逛。
the sidewalk. Here's how you can tell. Delaur's started playing really loud classical music through a speaker outside, and although I still see a fair number of people hanging out in front of the place, the owner says it's not nearly as many as before. Well, big change. It was mess, the hangar outside, and you know, just, they playing dice on the street outside the door, and it was crazy, but now it helps us a lot.
这就是你如何分辨出来的方法。DeLauer开始通过店外的扬声器播放非常响亮的古典音乐，虽然我仍然看到不少人在店前闲逛，但店主说人数已经远不如从前了。嗯，这是一个巨大的变化。以前这里很乱，外面聚集着人，你知道，他们就在门外的街上掷骰子，这太疯狂了，但现在这帮了我们大忙。
Even the customers telling us they see the change on the street here. I'm the owner of Delar's New System. My name is Facilima. When you have classical music, people who are young and cool don't really hang out there, so that's a way to deter teenagers. That is Selena Savage. And I'm co-author of the research project about unpleasant design.
甚至连顾客都告诉我们，他们看到了街道上的变化。我是DeLauer报刊亭的店主。我叫法西利马。当你播放古典音乐时，那些年轻又酷的人就不会真的在那里闲逛了，所以这是一种阻止青少年的方法。那是塞琳娜·萨维奇。我是关于“不友好设计”研究项目的合著者。
Playing classical music on loudspeakers is an example of what Selena calls unpleasant design. Unpleasant design is something that works well at deterring certain behaviors and certain uses from particularly public spaces. Along with her partner Gordon the Savichich, Selena collects and catalogs on pleasant designs. Unpleasant design was here since we started designing
在扬声器上播放古典音乐是塞琳娜所称的“不友好设计”的一个例子。不友好设计是指在阻止特定行为和特定用途方面非常有效，特别是在公共空间中。塞琳娜和她的搭档戈登·萨维奇一起收集并整理了这些不友好设计。不友好设计自我们开始设计公共空间或开始设计城市以来就一直存在。
public space or since we started designing cities. Unpleasant designs are meant to exert a kind of social control in public by targeting people who spend a lot of time in public spaces, especially the young and the homeless. And the designs often end up pushing these so-called undesirable people out of one space and into another. Music is only one method for deterrent teens from public space.
不友好设计旨在通过针对那些在公共空间花费大量时间的人（尤其是年轻人和无家可归者）来在公共场合施加一种社会控制。这些设计往往最终将这些所谓的“不受欢迎的人”从一个空间推向另一个空间。音乐只是阻止青少年进入公共空间的一种方法。
In 2009, the Nottinghamshire House of the States in England installed pink lighting to keep kids from congregating. Pink lights, which would emphasize the skin, like blemishes and on teenagers, which should result in teenagers not hanging out there. That's one of my favorite examples. Mine too, although there's not a lot of evidence
2009年，英国诺丁汉郡的议会安装了粉红色的灯光，以防止孩子们聚集。粉红色的灯光会强调青少年皮肤上的瑕疵，从而导致青少年不再在那里闲逛。这是我最喜欢的例子之一。我也是，尽管没有太多证据证明它有多有效。
that proves how effective it is. Pink lighting that plays on teenagers in securities is funny and kind of devious if a little far-fetched. Another more substantiated example of targeting and trying to eliminate undesirable behavior with light is the presence of blue lighting in public restrooms. I saw this in UK train stations quite a bit last time I was there. Blue light of a particular color makes the veins slightly less visible. You can't see your veins through your skin, so it's hard to find a target if you're an intravenous drug user.
利用青少年的不安全感来使用粉红色灯光既有趣又有点阴险，虽然有点牵强。另一个关于利用光线来针对并试图消除不受欢迎行为的更具实质性的例子是公共厕所中的蓝色灯光。我上次在英国火车站时经常看到这种情况。特定颜色的蓝光会使静脉变得不那么明显。你无法透过皮肤看到静脉，所以如果你是静脉注射吸毒者，就很难找到目标。
Then it became a very popular solution for all kind of publicly accessible toilets and even sometimes in buses. When your veins are not visible to you, you're obviously not going to be able to take any herring. According to Selina, lights are one of the original forms of public social control, for example. There was a bridge in a small town in Bosnia, specifically in the Cosba of Vyshegrad Bosnia in the early 1900s, where he Austrian government, who kind of annexed the country at that time, decided to implement street lighting and that was very unpleasant to the locals and the locals would
后来，这成为各种公共厕所甚至有时在公交车上非常流行的解决方案。当你的静脉对你不可见时，你显然无法进行任何注射。据塞琳娜说，灯光是公共社会控制的原始形式之一。例如，在20世纪初，波斯尼亚维舍格勒的一个小镇上有一座桥，当时奥匈帝国政府（当时吞并了该国）决定实施街道照明，这对当地人来说非常不友好，当地人每天晚上都会破坏灯光，而政府每天早上都会重新安装。
destroy the light every night and the government would reinstall it every morning. And so the idea that light is something unpleasant for free expression in public space is something that we completely forgot. We've since become so habituated to public lighting that our primary experience with streetlights is that they deter criminal activity and make us feel safe. Unless you're someone who laments the lack of stars in the night sky or lives in an apartment with a window right next to a streaming-linked bright bulb, you might never view streetlights as unpleasant at all.
因此，光线对公共空间中的自由表达是不友好的这一概念，是我们完全忘记了的东西。我们已经习惯了公共照明，以至于我们对路灯的主要体验是它们能阻止犯罪活动并让我们感到安全。除非你是那种哀叹夜空中缺乏星星的人，或者住在窗户紧挨着明亮路灯的公寓里，否则你可能根本不会认为路灯是不友好的。
Which is one of the reasons why the unpleasant design project wants to point it out, so that it gets recognized as being part of an overall design scheme that can take on a much uglier manifestation. Well, these studs may only be a few centimeters tall, but they've caused a big debate. This is from a BBC news story from 2014. The reporter Nick Beek is pointing to a set of angry-looking spikes that were installed in the concrete floor of a small alcove by the entrance to an apartment building. The spikes are clearly meant to stop people from sitting or lying there. Is this a legitimate way to prevent rough sleeping and possible anti-social behavior,
这也是“不友好设计”项目想要指出这一点的原因之一，这样它就能被识别为整体设计方案的一部分，而这种方案可能会呈现出更丑陋的表现形式。嗯，这些钉子可能只有几厘米高，但它们引发了巨大的争论。这是2014年BBC新闻报道中的内容。记者尼克·比克指着一套安装在公寓楼入口处小凹室混凝土底板上的愤怒的尖刺。这些尖刺显然是为了阻止人们坐在那里或躺在那里。这是一种防止露宿街头和可能的反社会行为的合法方式吗？
or are they a symbol of a heartless approach to homelessness? I hate you more than I know the answer. It's the second one. That spiked a huge debate, and even the mayor of London reacted and said that they should be removed and that we should not address homeless people in this way. The grocery chain Tesco also added spikes to areas outside the entrance to one of its stores in central London in 2014.
还是它们是对待无家可归者冷酷无情态度的象征？我讨厌你，因为我知道答案。是后者。这引发了巨大的争论，甚至伦敦市长也做出了反应，称应该拆除它们，我们不应该以这种方式对待无家可归者。连锁超市乐购也在2014年将其伦敦市中心一家门店外的区域增加了尖刺。
They were removed after days of public protest. Generally the debate was about the way we treat homelessness and is that something that we just want to remove from a particular space or is it something that we should somehow structurally address. Spikes to stop people from sitting or lying down evoked a wide variety of reactions from the public. The first time I saw someone lying here homeless couple actually, I didn't like it because I didn't like having to walk by them.
在经过几天的公众抗议后，它们被拆除了。总的来说，这场辩论是关于我们对待无家可归者的方式，以及这是否是我们只想从特定空间中移除的东西，还是我们应该以某种方式从结构上解决的问题。阻止人们坐下或躺下的尖刺引起了公众的广泛反应。我第一次看到有人躺在那里，一对无家可归的夫妇，我其实不喜欢它，因为我不喜欢不得不从他们身边走过。
That's trying to be very selfish. So when I saw those stats, I thought, good idea. So a lot of people are bothered by the presence of homeless people, but some are also alarmed by just how aggressive the spikes are. It's almost, looks harmful. You know, if you lie on those, you're going to get spiked. And so it sends that message, which I think is wrong. It's worth saying that these spikes are not just in England.
那是在试图变得非常自私。所以当我看到那些钉子时，我想，好主意。所以很多人被无家可归者的存在所困扰，但也有一些人对这些尖刺的攻击性感到震惊。它几乎看起来是有害的。你知道，如果你躺在上面，你会被扎伤。所以它传达了那个信息，我认为这是错误的。值得一提的是，这些尖刺不仅仅存在于英国。
We have them in the US too. Outside of our office is a window ledge where you naturally want to sit and sure enough, there are these black metal door-naub looking things that keep anyone from resting there. And one thing that makes these spikes in similar features, especially frustrating, is that they're just there. They're not moving. There's no arguing with them. You know, if you have a policeman who prohibits people from sleeping in a park, I think there is still some possible negotiation.
我们在美国也有。我们办公室外面有一个窗台，你自然想坐在那里，果然，那里有这些黑色的金属门把手状的东西，阻止任何人坐在那里。使这些尖刺和类似特征特别令人沮丧的一点是，它们就在那里。它们不会移动。你无法与它们争论。你知道，如果你有一个警察禁止人们在公园里睡觉，我认为仍然存在一些可能的协商。
And I think that's good. That's what society is about. The ongoing negotiation and ongoing change. But when we start using things that are immutable and unchangeable, like metal spikes, there is nothing that is going to change until they rust. I think that's the most important criteria for calling something unpleasant a design. It is something that you cannot negotiate with. We have all tried and probably failed to negotiate with one of the most common and aggravating forms of unpleasant design, public seating. Whether it's in a park or a bus stop or an airport, there are countless ways designers have made it so you cannot get comfortable.
我认为这很好。这就是社会的意义所在。持续的协商和持续的变化。但当我们开始使用像金属尖刺这样不可改变的东西时，在它们生锈之前，没有任何东西会改变。我认为这是将某物称为“不友好设计”最重要的标准。它是你无法与之协商的东西。我们都尝试过，也可能失败过，去与最常见和最令人恼火的“不友好设计”形式——公共座椅——进行协商。无论是在公园、公交车站还是机场，设计师们有无数种方法让你无法感到舒适。
And most especially cannot lie down. A classic is the bench with armrests in between, which of course let you rest your arm on the armrest, but at the same time they restrict any other kind of use, then sitting up right. The only way this bench can be used is by three people sitting next to each other and not looking at each other, which is not the only thing you can do on a bench, especially it's not the only normal and legal thing you can do on a bench. Some of the things that limiting the way something can be used is problematic.
尤其是不能躺下。一个经典例子是中间带有扶手的长椅，当然这让你可以在扶手上休息手臂，但同时它们限制了除坐直以外的任何其他用途。这张长椅唯一的用途就是三个人并排坐着，互不看对方，这并不是你在长椅上唯一能做的事情，尤其是它不是你在长椅上唯一正常且合法的事情。限制某物使用方式的某些做法是有问题的。
By attacking or addressing one particular problem, you actually generate many more problems and reduce complexity of possible behaviors in public space. It's not just dividers and armrests. In the unpleasant design book, they also point out benches that are mounted so high that your feet can't touch the ground, and therefore they're uncomfortable after a short period of time. And they document an increased prevalence of leaning supports at bus stops that you can rest against while standing, but they do not accommodate sitting or sleeping.
通过攻击或解决一个特定的问题，你实际上产生了更多的问题，并降低了公共空间中可能行为的复杂性。这不仅仅是隔板和扶手。在《不友好设计》一书中，他们还指出了安装得太高以至于你的脚无法触地的长椅，因此它们在短时间内就会让人感到不舒服。他们还记录了公交车站靠背支撑物的增加，你可以站着时靠在上面，但它们不适合坐着或睡觉。
But the object that Selina considers the masterpiece of unpleasant design is the Camden Bench. Basically, it is a design solution to 22, I think, anti-social behavior problems. The only thing it does not deter is sitting. The Camden Bench, so name because it was commissioned by Camden London Broe, is a strange, angular, sculpted, solid lump of concrete with rounded edges and slopes in unexpected places. A critic on medium name Frank Swain called it the perfect anti-object. Anti-sleeping because the shape makes it uncomfortable
但塞琳娜认为是不友好设计杰作的物体是卡姆登长椅。基本上，它是针对22个（我想是）反社会行为问题的设计解决方案。它唯一不阻止的就是坐着。卡姆登长椅之所以这样命名，是因为它是由伦敦卡姆登区委托设计的，它是一个奇怪的、有棱角的、雕塑般的、坚固的混凝土块，边缘圆润，在意想不到的地方有斜坡。Medium上的一位评论家弗兰克·斯温称它为完美的“反物体”。反睡觉，因为它的形状让人躺在上面不舒服。
to sleep on. Anti-drug dealing because there are no slots or crevices in which the high drugs. Anti-thep because the recesses near the ground allow people to store bags behind their legs and away from would be criminals. Anti-scapeboard because the edges on the bench fluctuate in height making grinding difficult. Antiliter because there are no surfaces or crevices or litter can accrue. Antigrophidi because it has a special coating to repel paint.
反毒品交易，因为没有可以藏毒的槽口或缝隙。反盗窃，因为靠近地面的凹槽允许人们将包存放在腿后，远离潜在的罪犯。反滑板，因为长椅上的边缘高度波动，使得磨板变得困难。反乱扔垃圾，因为没有表面或缝隙可以堆积垃圾。反涂鸦，因为它有特殊的涂层来排斥油漆。
And all those goals are pretty noble. Except for sleeping and skateboarding, I don't really want the other activities happening in public spaces I go to either. But selling this of it finds this litany of anti-measures, demoralizing. It discourages 22 things, it encourages two sitting and sitting together. When we expect people to do bad things to the bench before we think of anything good that people might do to the bench, I think that's a very sad approach to public space. It's also a contagious approach to public space. There's a chapter in the
所有这些目标都相当高尚。除了睡觉和滑板，我也不太希望我去的地方发生其他活动。但塞琳娜发现这一连串的反措施令人沮丧。它阻止了22件事，只鼓励了两件事：坐着和坐在一起。当我们期望人们对长椅做坏事，而不是想到人们可能对长椅做的好事时，我认为这是一种对待公共空间非常悲哀的方法。这也是一种具有传染性的公共空间处理方法。书中有一章是关于
unpleasant design book that's devoted to all the unpleasant designs used to thwart pigeons and cities, anti-pigeons bikes and nets are everywhere. And even if you're like Salina and aware of these measures and skeptical of our war on pigeons, you might not have a choice in whether or not to use them. A week after we have published the book, we had a confirmation of this. We didn't even notice, but on the balcony doors, we actually had antipygdened spikes. And then, due to somebody hanging out on the balcony, who was, I don't know, a bit clumsy and they destroyed these spikes on one side and we didn't even notice that. Suddenly the balcony was filled with pigeon shit.
《不友好设计》一书专门讨论了城市中用于阻挠鸽子的所有不友好设计，防鸽尖刺和网随处可见。即使你像塞琳娜一样意识到这些措施并对我们的“鸽子战争”持怀疑态度，你可能也无法选择是否使用它们。在我们出版这本书一周后，我们得到了证实。我们甚至没有注意到，但在阳台门上，我们实际上有防鸽尖刺。然后，由于有人在阳台上闲逛，不知道是谁，有点笨手笨脚，他们毁坏了一侧的这些尖刺，我们甚至没有注意到。突然间，阳台上到处都是鸽子粪。
Pigeons might not be overwhelming if the population is spread throughout a city, but the ubiquity of pigeon spikes concentrate pigeons in the few places where there are no spikes. Sona argues that's when the problem is created. And that should not be the way to solve any kind of interest conflicts over a space, but yes, we immediately fix our spikes. There is always an aspect of coercion to design. Design is used to get you to buy things, to use your iPhone in a certain way, sometimes without you even being aware of it. And these pieces of hostile and unpleasant architecture are no different.
如果鸽子种群分布在整个城市，它们可能不会让人难以忍受，但防鸽尖刺的普遍存在将鸽子集中在没有尖刺的少数地方。塞琳娜认为，这就是问题产生的时候。这不应该是解决任何空间利益冲突的方式，但是的，我们立即修复了我们的尖刺。设计中总是存在一种强制的方面。设计被用来让你购买东西，以某种方式使用你的iPhone，有时甚至是你没有意识到的。这些敌对和不友好的建筑作品也不例外。
Design is something that is supposed to transmit a certain use of this object, otherwise it would have not been designed. However, I think it is very problematic when we start excluding people by design. The reason we need a critical theory of unpleasant design is so we can recognize the coercion that is taking place in our public spaces. We need to know when we're replacing human interaction and nuance and empathy with hard, physical, non-negotiable solutions.
设计是一种旨在传达该物体某种用途的东西，否则它就不会被设计出来。然而，我认为当我们开始通过设计排斥人们时，这是非常有问题的。我们需要对不友好设计进行批判性理论的原因，是为了让我们能够识别在公共空间中发生的强制行为。我们需要知道我们何时用坚硬、物理、不可协商的解决方案取代了人类的互动、细微差别和同理心。
And this is what we wanted to achieve with this book, to start a debate. There will always be people who believe this is a good way and people who think it's terrible. And we are somehow not extreme in our opinion. We're really the observers. And now you're an observer too. Whether you think a certain form of design is exclusionary,
这就是我们想要通过这本书实现的目标，开启一场辩论。总会有相信这是一种好方法的人，也会有认为这很糟糕的人。而我们的观点在某种程度上并不极端。我们真的是观察者。现在你也是观察者了。无论你认为某种形式的设计是排他性的，
but serves a greater good, or just hostile and offensive. It's important to be aware of the decisions that are being made for you, because most likely, unpleasant design is put there to make things more pleasant for someone just like you. 99% of visible is Sam Green span to Laney Hall, Kirk-Cold Stead, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, Sharif, Yusef, and me Roman Mars. A bunch of the music this week came from our pal Melodium, Your Life, Will Improve,
但服务于更大的利益，还是仅仅是敌对和冒犯性的。重要的是要意识到为你做出的决定，因为很可能，不友好设计被放在那里是为了让像你这样的人感到更舒适。《99%隐形》团队包括萨姆·格林斯潘、兰尼·霍尔、柯克·科尔德斯特德、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、谢里夫·优素福，以及我，罗曼·马斯。本周的许多音乐来自我们的朋友Melodium，《你的生活将会改善》，
Measurably, when you buy and incorporate Melodium into your daily routine. It'll be like being inside a 99% Invisible episode all the time. Find Melodium on Bandcamp and on a bandin building records. It'll be like being inside a 99% invisible episode all the time. Find Melodium on Bandcamp and on a band and building records. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced are the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. You can follow me on Twitter at RomanMars and on Instagram at the RomanMars and the rest of the 99PI crew are all on Twitter and Instagram as well to search around.
当你购买并将Melodium融入你的日常生活时，效果会很明显。这就像一直置身于《99%隐形》的一集中。在Bandcamp和Bandin Building Records上找到Melodium。这就像一直置身于《99%隐形》的一集中。在Bandcamp和Bandin Building Records上找到Melodium。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，由加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的ArcSign建筑与室内设计事务所制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，在Instagram上关注@theRomanMars，99PI团队的其他成员也都在Twitter和Instagram上，搜索一下即可。
But the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to click around the hundreds and hundreds of cool stories on 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动的最好方法是点击99pi.org上数百个很酷的故事。Radio Tapio，来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。